so my name is Alex as Wes mentioned I
work at cockroach labs which is a New
York city-based startup so very local
that is trying to build a cloud native
sequel database our overarching mission
is to make data easy and we think that
this is one of the best ways that we can
do so so today I'm just gonna talk a
little bit about what it means to be a
cloud native database you know why it's
important to have a database like this
and most importantly some of the
techniques that we use to build this
database and give it the properties that
we want in it so before we get started
it's useful to have a general
understanding of what cloud native means
so I know cloud native is a word that
gets thrown around a lot and sometimes
in different ways depending on what
circles you run in before working at
cockroach labs I spent a couple years
working on the Cooper Nettie's project
at Google where I was neck deep in
containers and cloud native and all that
jargon all the time so I have some idea
of what it means and hopefully we can
get to a general agreement on that
before we move forward into the actual
engineering so a cloud native system has
a number of properties of which these
are some of the key ones in my opinion a
cloud native system is something where
you aren't too reliant on any individual
machine or any individual process you
can scale it out horizontally when you
need to add more capacity it's built to
handle and automatically recover from
failures and it doesn't need a lot of
operator overhead in the process of
doing this so when you think about you
know how Netflix runs their compute they
have a bunch of short-lived ephemeral
VMs that they don't get too attached to
they treat them as if they're a bunch of
cattle they don't they don't treat them
as if they're their pets that need to be
individually cared for and if something
fails it doesn't matter they discrete
spin up a few new ones and everything or
covers and that's really the ideal of a
cloud native system these systems tend
to be things that work really well in
orchestration frameworks so they can be
packaged up into containers very often
stuck on the top of kubernetes or swarm
or maze hose
and to run well in those kinds of
environments on the other hand just for
understanding something that isn't cloud
native is something that lacks one or
more of those properties now it can't
scale out it might rely on a single
point of failure maybe it's even just a
single monolithic application maybe it's
a manual failover process so it can't
automatically recover from problems or
tied to a particular piece of hardware
and so these properties aren't anything
totally new they're not mind-blowing ly
unique they sound like a lot of
databases out there on the market today
there's a lot of no sequel databases
that offer these scale out automatically
recoverable properties that you want a
number of big companies built on them
but these systems typically lack things
like strong consistency and generalized
transactions that the developers of your
got when they used traditional
relational databases and so nowadays
when you pick a database you kind of
have to choose your poison do you want a
traditional sequel database that has
great consistency gives you transactions
to make developing your application
easier but you give up things like
horizontal scaling and fault tolerance
or you choose a no sequel database and
have to work around the lack of strong
consistency in your application a lack
of generalized transactions and this is
a tough choice there are good things
about each of course at this point some
people might say you know great great
businesses great services great
companies have been built on top of note
sequel databases without consistency
without transactions maybe they're not
important but I think if you've ever
worked with one of these systems you can
remember having to spend time upfront
when you're designing a new a new
service thinking about how to work
around your database you know thinking
about the edge cases whether your
application will handle reading stale
data occasionally how you can update
multiple pieces of your database in a
way such that if one of the updates
fails you can recover even though you
don't have those transactions and even
if you do this perfectly up front and
you build a perfect system that doesn't
need consistency or transactions what
happens a year later when you've left
the team a few junior developers have
taken over and have to implement some
new business features they don't know
exactly everything that you did when you
built the system and they're very likely
to accidentally hit an edge case where
in production a customer will have a bug
and you won't be able to easily
reproduce it because it's it's a
Heisenberg it only comes up when a
system is overloaded or has networking
problems
there's really a lot of business cost to
having to work around a database it
doesn't give you proper proper
consistency in transactions and you know
and transactions you know the same
reasoning applies is for consistency
this is a quote from the Google spanner
paper spanner was a project at Google
effectively trying to do the same thing
it was an inspiration for the cockroach
labs company spanner is a scale out
sequel database that's meant to span
very broad geographic areas even around
the entire world with strong consistency
and general transactions and Google as a
company thinks it is worth it to to deal
with the cost of building the system up
front and then with any latency problems
that might arise as a result of using it
rather than having all of their
developers have to reason about eventual
consistency and the lack of transactions
it's just a better business case for
them to take the burden off their
developers and occasionally have to deal
with a performance issue then it would
be to always have to deal with with a
lack of consistency and we think the
same sort of reasoning in the same
cost-benefit trade-off applies to a
large number of projects if you had a
database that could do this even if it
performed a little bit worse yet
slightly more latency it would be an
easy choice for most for most services
so since this is so useful you know you
might ask why has nobody done this other
than Google why is they no open source
product that does this why don't we have
tens of these different databases
available today and the question of
course is the answer of course is just
that it's really hard it's not as if
when people came came to the drawing
board to design a new database 10 years
ago when they were building dynamo or
big table or Cassandra they didn't sit
down and think transactions are too
confusing we don't want to include them
it was just a matter of prioritizing a
scale and fault tolerance more highly
and not being able to squeeze in
transactions and consistency as well
building a database is hard building a
distributed system is hard dealing with
time and ordering in a distributed
system is even harder and there is also
a performance penalty if you have to do
multiple round trips or even one round
trip between different nodes in a
database to commit data
so there are trade-offs and it's not
easy but we think that if it existed in
a good package everyone would want to
use it and so if we can agree that these
properties are useful if you can agree
that you want a distributed system to
have some notion of truth to be reliably
consistent then let's get into some of
the details of how you do that so we're
gonna focus on just a few properties of
cockroach TV a few layers of how that
it's built cockroach TV being the
database the cockroach Labs is working
on we're gonna focus on how it
distributes its data and replicates that
data amongst all the nodes in the
cluster we're gonna talk a little bit
about how it keeps that data in sync
using consensus and then how we build
truly distributed transactions on top of
those foundational layers so before we
get into too many details it's useful to
have just a brief background on how the
system is layered so it's it's
structured as a system of light as a set
of layers where each layer only has to
care about the black box right beneath
it so even though we're a sequel
database the the sequel part of our
system isn't actually the most
interesting part most of the guarantees
about the distributed system provides
are packed into that transactional key
value layer that provides consistent
operations on keys and values and
arbitrary transactions across those keys
and values in our sequel layer on top
just relies on those guarantees to map
sequel operations into a series of key
value operations like gits puts
conditional puts scans and deletes so
I'm not going to talk too much about
that mapping of sequel to key value
operations today but I'm happy to talk
about it on office hours afterwards if
anyone has questions what we are going
to focus on is how that transactional
key value layer distributes data
replicates the data and keeps it
consistent so we'll start out by looking
at how we distribute the data across the
cluster which is a very key property
when building a system that has to be
able to recover from failures and scale
out arbitrarily and the two key
questions you have to first answer when
you're thinking about building us
like this is how do you divide the data
up into chunks and then once you've
distributed those chunks how do you know
where they're all located there are two
main approaches to solving this problem
that have been used a lot in past
systems
the first is hashing the second is order
preserving the the hashing approach is
sort of what you would expect given a
key to a piece of data you hash the key
and then that hash maps on to one of the
nodes in the cluster so this is great
because you don't need any kind of
lookup table to figure out where data
lives given the key that you want to
find you just hash it and you know
exactly what node to look at and that's
awesome the problem is that because
hashing doesn't respect ordering they
makes it really hard to do ordered scans
over your data and for a sequel database
that's absolutely critical you can't
build a sequel database without an
ordered system underneath it imagine
trying to build an index on an unordered
system you can't do it
so in cockroach TB we've had to go the
order preserving approach and this this
satisfies our need for efficient scans
linearly over data but it requires some
additional indexing metadata that we
have to keep track of so that given a
key we can look up where it's located
because otherwise we wouldn't know what
machine it's on so our data looks
something like this we break up the key
space into a series of ranges from the
beginning of the key space to the end
and each range lives on one or more
nodes additionally we have to have an
indexing structure that just indicates
where each range lives in the cluster
and this looks basically like you would
expect and so when you need to look up a
key first you have to look in this this
indexing range this this shard index
find the range that your key is in and
then that will have the information on
what nodes that data is on and so we
have to keep this shard index available
so that all the nodes know about it
because our system has you know
symetrical nodes there is no master that
you go look up this index on every node
knows how to access this index
and so if you want to do a scan it works
effectively as you would expect you look
up the start key find the range that's
in lookup the end key find the range
that it is in and then scan all the
ranges in between and a nice benefit of
this order preserving approach is that
when a shard gets too large we can just
split it in half and update the index in
some hashing schemes if you end up with
too much data hash to a particular node
you have to actually modify your hashing
algorithm in some way in order to spread
that data off the note that it's ended
up on so all we have to do is split it
and then update the index and if you
kind of squint at it a little bit this
looks a little bit like a b-tree you
have the data structure that's at the
heart of most relational database
systems where you have an ordered tree
pointing downward where the actual data
is held in the leaves so it's kind of
like a funny funny coincidence that we
ended up at a similar data structure the
other key part of how we distribute the
data is where we put it
so we try to keep the data separated so
that we don't have you know all of it on
one node obviously we want to balance it
but most importantly we have to
replicate it because if we only kept one
copy of the data as soon as the node
dives you have you have unavailability
that data's not there and if the disk
dies you know the disk fails you might
have lost the data so we have to keep
the data stored on multiple machines and
we have a scheduling algorithm allocates
these ranges to these nodes and it's
very dynamic as nodes are added where we
rebalance constantly to get data spread
out on to the new nodes which improves
performance improves availability it
limits the damage that one node dying
can do and then as a node dies we also
have to make sure that we don't lose
data in those cases so let's look at
adding a new node now we add a new node
here it starts out empty and one of the
nodes that has data that recognizes
there's a new note it has a lot of space
and I'd like to to take some burden off
of myself so
we're gonna move range three onto this
new note once we copy the data over we
can kill one of the old ranges so note
three is able to save some space and
this isn't just disk space this is also
memory for caching it's compute for
handling queries that are reading that
data so it helps balance all the
resources of the cluster when we move
the ranges around and so we can do this
until we have a reasonably good balance
of data amongst the nodes in the cluster
and again there isn't some master node
coordinating all this it's it's a fairly
dynamic process that's that's
organically happening within a cluster
as nodes notice that they have too much
load on them and other nodes don't have
much load on them that they no node
three will ask a node for hey will you
take this range off my hands and node
four will have to respond yes I'll take
that the other interesting case here in
the balancing of data is when a node
fails so if we lose a node we're down to
fewer copies of our data than we want so
we want to keep a minimum of three
copies of art of each range at all times
for availability purposes
so once node two dies we only have two
copies of a couple of our ranges so
again the nodes recognize this and
create a new replica and the node that
has some space so the the ranges that do
have that data are going to have to work
extra hard to copy the data to a new
node to ensure that the data isn't lost
and yeah once once all the data is
replicated away we can forget about the
old ones so in order to facilitate this
dynamic movement of data we need to
ensure that our ranges aren't too big so
we found 64 megabytes experimentally
it's a fairly good size for this so such
the ranges are small enough that we can
move them reasonably quickly when a node
fails but they're not so big or over
there that sounds small that we have
tons and tons of indexing overhead and
tracking where all these ranges are oh
yeah there's nothing incredibly novel
about what we're doing here in the data
distribution part but but it really
provides the foundation of the system
for how we how we track where data is
how we keep it alive how we keep it
available that's really necessary to
provide a reliable cloud native system
you know if we didn't have the data
spread across multiple nodes we couldn't
scale out and we couldn't recover from
failures in the like of course once you
have data spread across a number of
places the the the huge question becomes
how do you keep it in sync
in a sequel database you expect your
results to be consistent acid that a
traditional acronym is key to a sequel
database your data has to be kept
consistent and so you don't want
different copies of data to be giving
you different results because that's not
providing true consistency I might even
just be downright incorrect in most
cases so we have to use some sort of
system to keep the data in sync across
nodes again there are there are two
fairly common alternatives here the
first being primary secondary
replication which many people here are
probably familiar with if you've used
you know a traditional sequel database
before and consensus which you again
might might have heard it before it
might have used primary secondary
replication has been used for quite a
while and in theory sounds awesome so
you have a primary node that receives
all your rights and then when it
receives a write it replicates that that
right on to a secondary one or more
secondary nodes and then that secondary
also has the data and so reads can
happen on either node if the primary
fails you can promote one of the
secondaries to primary and everything's
great of course there are there are
complications here there there are extra
questions you have to deal with if you
do this primary secondary replication
asynchronously
meaning that the primary gets a right
the primary persists that right and then
acknowledges the right before sending
the data along to the secondary it's
possible that the secondary is out of
date so anyone reading from the
secondary could be missing new data and
similarly if the master fails the the
secondary might not have all the data
that the master had when at the time
that it failed if you opt for
synchronous replication meaning that the
secondary has to get the data before the
primary will acknowledge any rights to
users then all of a sudden you're
bringing your availability way down
because if the secondary fails your
primary can't accept rights anymore so
you've taken what already is a single
point of failure and almost turned it
into two points of failure because if
the secondary can't can't act writes in
the primary
I can't hack them either so you're
hurting your availability there and also
your latency as well so there's also
this problem of ensuring that when you
do a failover your clients know which
which replica to connect to so this is a
fairly complicated approach with a lot
of edge cases it works really well in
the happy case but when things fail it's
it's likely you're gonna lose some data
or be reading stale data for a while
their consensus approach to ensuring
that your data is in sync is a little
different so you have an odd number of
nodes and the idea is that when a
majority of them agree on something then
that then that thing is the truth so
when a Wright comes in once a majority
of the nodes in this case two out of
three because we we default to three
replicas of things once two out of three
nodes have written it then that day that
is written so there's there's been a lot
of research on consensus but here's sort
of a drill a simplified version of what
it looks like in practice you have a
leader and a couple of followers and
this is because in a number of consensus
systems it works by electing a leader
that receives all rights and forwards
those along to the followers so we have
a leader here that's received a right
for cherry it writes it to its own disc
and sends it along to its followers as
soon as either of them writes that key
as well the data is committed even
before it's actually acknowledged the
data is committed as soon as it's
written not a majority of the nodes but
in most cases things won't be failing
and so the second you know the follower
will act that data back and the leader
will acknowledge it to the user so this
does add an extra round trip to your
rights because the leader has to get an
acknowledgment from a follower in order
to tell the user that the data is
written of course as always the
interesting question is what happens
when things are failing and so let's
look at that case a little bit remember
that data is written as soon as a
majority of the nodes have written it so
in this case the leader receives a write
for cherry and it writes it but before
it's able to pass that right along it
dies and wallets gone a new leader is
elected so we have this first leader
over here it still has the data that I
wrote but the new leader doesn't the
other follower doesn't so according to
the rule this data is not committed and
when the new leader receives a read for
that key it will see that it's not on a
majority of the nodes that data is not
committed so it will return that the key
was not found to the user and the
follower will be told to remove cherry
from its data that data is not not part
of the database so we in particular use
the raft because it's consensus protocol
as was mentioned by will a couple talks
ago this is as you said it's sorry it's
meant to be a simplification previous
consensus protocols like paxos paxos was
conceived of in the 90s and kind of
languished for a long time because it
was so complicated that nobody could
really implement it in a practical way
and there still were not really good
open-source implementations of it graft
was come up with by a PhD student a few
years ago purely to be more
understandable and at this point there
are an incredible number of solid
implementations that you can get out
there if you look for them out in open
source so using consensus in your
service is now a practical thing to do
because there are implementations out
there that you can rely on in particular
we we share an implementation with the
sed team at CD being another database
practically in our database we run one
consensus group per each range of data
so we have a lot of ranges replicated
across the nodes each range gets its own
consensus group so it all writes to that
range are kept consistent across all the
replicas of it there are a number of
engineering complications here around
how we handle raft around handling
adding new members removing members
splitting ranges dealing with a large
number of ranges and consensus groups
that we have in our system but these are
all engineering problems that can be
worked around once you have that
foundation
you know and so yeah they're really
really the key point here is the
consensus provides atomic replication
each right that comes in is either
written or it isn't there is no sense of
like OneNote having it in another node
not having it because you know when
reads are served they will ensure that
it's only returned if the majority of
notes have it and that's really useful
to have having any kind of guarantee
that you can rely on in a distributed
system is incredibly useful and so the
next question that comes up of course is
you have this great consistency per
range but your database doesn't fit in a
64 megabyte range that'd be a tiny
database that'd be silly so we have to
worry about operations that hit multiple
ranges and that's where distributed
transactions come in so you can't have a
sequel database without having
transactions and if we have a
distributed database our transactions
have to be distributed as well because
the data will often not all be on the
same node and we want to be a full
database we want to achieve full
Postgres compatibility so we have to
have the traditional asset semantics
where your your commit is all or nothing
it's consistent each each transaction is
isolated from all others and we default
to the the strong isolation level known
as serializable where if every every
transaction that commits the the in
state of your system is equivalent to as
if each transaction had been executed in
some serial order so there is no
interference at all between transactions
in the out ending data in your database
but to understand how we do distributed
transactions it's useful to first take a
look at how transactions work in a
single node database so you know in a
traditional relational database that
runs on one machine atomicity and
durability are provided by the
underlying filesystem by a log write to
that file system so when a transaction
comes in
it reads some data it writes some data
and each of those rights is only
provisional it's not guaranteed to stick
around so these rights are tagged with
the transaction ID
and those rights aren't considered
committed until there is a commit
message in the log for that transaction
ID so if the transaction comes in rights
a couple entries and then aborts those
things are not considered committed and
any read should not return those at that
point but once the commit is written to
the log that single operation commits
all the data and so that's how they
provide an Amissah T of course in a
distributed transaction we don't have a
single log that we can write to we don't
have a single disk that we can write
this transaction log to so we bootstrap
it off of raft so we use raft the
consensus protocol to store a
transaction record that we can then
switch to committed the anatomic write
and because that consensus group is
replicated and the rights to it are
atomic we achieved the atomicity and
durability the same as in a log right to
local disk so a transaction can come in
we can write a bunch of things across
the database that all are tagged with
the transaction ID and when the
transaction is done we write that that
transaction ID is committed and that
switches all those provisional rights
from not committed to committed in one
single step so let's take a little look
at how that works a user starts a new
transaction and so we create a
transaction record for it in this case
transaction 1 and it's in the pending
state because it hasn't committed it
hasn't been rolled back it hasn't been
aborted
it's just ongoing so then the user puts
a key they write a key they write
another key and these keys are in
different ranges
you might notice so we can't just use a
single consensus group here and then
they decide to commit the transaction as
soon as they do that the transaction is
committed any read that comes along and
sees our write with a transaction ID
attached to it has to go look up whether
that transaction is committed yet before
they can reliably return that data and
then in the background we can then go
clean up those
provisional rights that background
cleanup doesn't change the semantics of
anything as soon as the commit record is
written that data is persisted but
cleaning up those intents prevent reads
from having to go do that lookup so it's
a performance optimization and again
this is the happy case this is when
nothing's failing when there are no
conflicts so of course we have to take a
quick look at how we deal with some
kinds of conflicts because in databases
a lot of the complexity comes from
trying to prevent different transactions
from interfering with each other in some
way you don't want to ongoing
transactions to see each other's data
before it's been committed so in this
case begins start off the transaction
writing a key and then we have another
transaction come in and try to read that
key so transaction one has not committed
yet at this point so transaction 2 sees
this this key here with transaction ID
tagged to it because it has a tag on it
it has to go look at the transaction
record for that transaction so it checks
the status of it and in this case sees
that it's pending so there's some
funniness here with timestamps depending
on which times transactions timestamp is
first it might do different things here
but we're going to assume that
transaction two has an earlier timestamp
than transaction one just for simplicity
and in this case it sees that
transaction 1 as a later time stamp it
hasn't committed yet transaction 1 can
return without returning that value
it'll say that it wasn't found
if transaction 2 had a later time stamp
than transaction 1 we may have had to
push transaction ones timestamp back but
that's getting pretty far into some of
the details of how we do distributed
transactions so so transaction 1 might
have had to commit at a later time span
and look at one other conflict here a
write conflict or two to two
transactions they're trying to write the
same data so we have two transaction
records here the second transaction
wants to write to a key the transaction
one is written to but not yet committed
now this would not be allowed we could
not let both of these transactions go
forward that would be a right anomaly so
one of the transactions has to lose
notably here we don't use locks if you
look at how something like my sequel
works they use locks that get held on
keys while a transaction is ongoing so
in this case transaction two would try
to write to Chery but it wouldn't be
able to get the lock because transaction
one held it we use what's known as an
optimistic concurrency protocol where we
don't use locks but we detect conflicts
as they occur
so normally things can just proceed
along happily without needing to worry
about locks but once we notice that two
transactions are overlapping in some way
that's not allowed we have to abort one
of them or at least push one of them
back so in this case transaction two
aborts transaction one says I'm gonna
take over I'm gonna use this key you're
gonna have to restart if you want to use
it that prevents them from from having
an anomaly so once transaction two has
done that it can go forward right the
key and commit if transaction one what
still wants to write that key it's gonna
have to restart from scratch and reput
that key
so that's that's a couple quick examples
of how we deal with conflicts there is
more detail more more more to it than
just that but that's really the
foundation and its really all keyed on
unwrapped so if we have to didn't
provide us atomicity and durability we
wouldn't be able to provide anything we
couldn't provide consistency or
isolation and so yeah there's a lot more
to talk about if you want to go check
out more read our blog we have a bunch
of great posts detailing exactly how we
do this without locks how we map sequel
unto Kb etc and I definitely recommend
you check it out if you're curious to
learn more so just to summarize we're
trying to build a sequel database that
works really well in modern cloud
environments you can bring together the
best of sequel databases with their
strong print guarantees that help
developers and no sequel databases with
their great operational attributes that
keeps them up keep them up keep them
available keep them serving
it's not easy to build this but but it
once it's built it's much easier people
to use is the goal when we do this using
some few techniques we have to
distribute data carefully keep it
consistent provide transactions on top
of it so thanks a lot for listening to
the talk check out more info on our
website you can read the code read the
design Doc's on our github repository
feel free to ask any questions
both afterwards or via email if you'd
like are there any questions right now
are you doing how you maintain ensuring
that there's no phantoms your read-write
set based on that ranges are the
individual keys it's both so we have a
timestamp cache as well where we track
which keys and which ranges have been
written or read to so if someone's read
arranged you know use a predicate to
read some sort of range we do track that
and we need to prevent the intents we
have you know a bunch of Jepson testing
set up that it provides it verifies our
serial ID facility can you talk about
how the range indexes are stored and
distributed do you have to keep a
complete copy of the range index on
every node and if so how does that
effects scale so we don't keep a copy of
the range index on every node what we do
is they're treated as any other range so
we keep three replicas of them in most
deployments their location is gossiped
so we use a gossip protocol to ensure
that all the nodes know the locations of
those three replicas of that first range
and once you do that that's gossiped
everywhere so nodes can go and look up
data if they need it
we also cache it to avoid the
performance overhead of doing those
lookups every time and it's if we have a
cache miss if some data has changed and
we still use a cache version of it it's
okay because we'll just try to talk to a
node that doesn't have a range and be
told that we're wrong and then we can go
do the lookup so we effectively we
gossiped the location of those ranges
update them normally as if they're a
normal rap group and then cache it and I
guess that can exceed 60 for mega bytes
in size so we have a two layer index
that's a good point so the first index
points to the location of the other
index box and with the two layer index
we can get up to exabytes of data great
thanks
I have a question on the Concord right
scenario that you have it looks like I
don't know too much about data it looks
a lot like software transactional memory
with MVCC we do use a BCC and that's not
too much about software transactional
very similar I guess so you restart the
transaction if there was a class right
so how does this perform in a lot of
right yeah it's a great question so the
database works best when there's not
high contention no we do ensure that
long transactions can finish using some
priorities so if you get aborted a bunch
your priority will jump up and you'll be
less likely to abort it again so we do
ensure forward progress for very right
heavy workloads they have a lot of
contention on individual keys we offer a
lower level of isolation snapshot
isolation which is actually the default
level of isolation in many sequel
databases that allows for rights to
proceed a little better but the only
problem is if your rights are hitting
the same keys if your rights are going
to different keys there's not a problem
and there won't be isolation issues so
sorry I made misses but the so when when
engine transaction starts it needs to to
check to see if there's a completing
transaction that's currently kinda
pending right like how does it know like
where's that data stored so so you said
that it's is it's handled by RAF but you
have a rough instance per range yeah so
when a transaction starts we don't
actually create a transaction record
until the first operation for that
transaction happens but say I write
comes in for the transaction and that
goes to a particular range as a
performance optimization we put the
transaction record in that same range as
the data that we just wrote and then in
the provisional writes that point to the
transaction record they should say where
it is so that's a little a little much
to explain in words rather than a
diagram but the provisional writes point
to the transaction record so that they
readers know where to look for it and
typically we put it in the same range as
the first right
and what happens if the transaction
spans multiple ranges that's okay
because the in the second range the
provisional right will point back to the
first range where the transaction record
lives what happens when one of the nodes
go down dude anytime so if the node
remember we're using raft for all of
this
so each raft group is Rupp going to be
replicated to three different nodes
typically and so if one node goes down
if it was a follower of a given raft
group it was part of the transaction
nothing really happens it doesn't matter
because the leader will still be able to
get an AK from the other follower if a
node goes down that had a leader for one
of those graft groups there will be a
short delay around the second or so
maybe two seconds
I forget what our current timeout is
before a new leader gets elected and can
continue that transaction but the new
leader will have all the data and so the
transaction won't have to abort or
anything it's just we has to wait for a
new leader to be elected that can
continue taking on the operations